oh so I'm just allowed to say I'm gonna
kill myself and then I met her crazy
he's the one that messed up not you well
don't make it harder on you Khloe
Kardashian reveals Tristan Thompson
expressed suicidal thoughts after the
cheating scandal with Kylie's BFF Jordan
Woods came to light the fact that Khloe
is sitting here heartbroken but still
worrying about Tristan's feelings and
the possibilities of him being upset her
possibly hurting himself I mean it just
goes to show that Khloe is an
unbelievable person on part one of the
two-part season finale of Keeping Up
with the Kardashians
Khloe says her ex was texting her
apologies saying he felt so bad about
what he did that he may hurt himself do
you think he's gonna hurt himself
Kristin's admission was just the tip of
the iceberg as Coko thought she may be
pregnant just days before the drama
unfolded after suffering major migraines
genuinely I cannot believe it I know she
saw this I almost wish I was I could
just say that's why I'm nauseous I think
that if she was just to you know settle
down and not have all these stressful
situations coming at her one after
another she probably wouldn't have these
migraines the episode showed the whole
family reacting to the make-out that
allegedly went down at an Airbnb at
during the NBA all-star weekend in Los
Angeles
[Applause]
literally like Shaylee she provides for
her whole family off of what you have
given her if she would do this to one of
us she would do the same thing to Kylie
we also learned what Jordan allegedly
told Khloe it all went down Jordan never
once has Jordan said I'm sorry I'm sorry
Jordan anticipated how the episode would
play out when she spoke with et last
week would you think when you saw that
you know everyone has their truth in
their story and so you just go go with
it everyone has the right to speak their
truth the 21 year old model admitted
she's moving on and hopes everyone
involved can do the same life moves on
money doesn't stop world doesn't stop
and hopefully everyone is just you know
going forward hopefully the sky's the
limit
so trying new things getting into acting
I have my activewear line more designing
and just really moving forward and
keeping positive people around me a life
is short you know tomorrow is not
promised I was just hoping for a better
outcome for my daughter
you